now the American left has worked
overtime for decades slowly but surely
destroying almost every Norm that we
Americans once held dear
sexual Norms they're gone
this is Kenzie she fell in love with
Legacy and they fell in love with Amber
people assume that I'm I'm the guy I'm
the center and I have two girlfriends
yeah no she has two girlfriends she has
two girlfriends and I have two
girlfriends if anyone has ever doubted
or questioned being in a polyamorous
relationship it's not as bad as you
think
no judging oh of course religious and
cultural norms they're under assault
[Music]
how edgy business Norms gone
Nike reportedly said to unveil a new
gender inclusive apparel line for
children as part of its Pride
Celebration a leaked email obtained by
the daily wire also shows the Nike
United Pride network is offering Pride
themed Fitness events and a chance for
children to talk with a doctor who has
performed gender surgeries on
adolescence
I love Maria's face there historic Norms
obliterated
generations of black children have been
made to feel inferior in these United
States of America and it works racism
New York is now mandating a new racial
Equity class and its state universities
and if you don't pass you don't graduate
and of course legal Norms they're gone
groundbreaking shift in American
constitutional law the Supreme Court
appears poised to strike down the
landmark Roe v Wade decision the leak of
the 98-page document is unprecedented
it's all unprecedented and it's all very
disturbing because these Norms are or
were part of the glue that held together
much of our society and without respect
for those basic ideals
everything else begins to pull apart
and then it gives way for the Smashing
of other rules that exist for good
reason
like the unspoken rule that you don't
try to put your political opponents in
jail by weaponizing the doj and Intel
agencies against your political
opponents
and then the follow-on norm that during
legal proceedings you don't like bits of
evidence to the media to try to convict
someone in the court of public opinion
well this may have been what happened
earlier today in the Trump documents
case of course run by special prosecutor
Jack Smith less than 24 hours after news
broke of the indictment CNN somehow
claims it got its hands on a tape
recording of Donald Trump allegedly
saying that he has a Secret Pentagon
document about attacking Iran several
sources told CNN the recording captures
the sound of paper rustling as if Trump
was waving the document around though
it's not clear if it was the actual Iran
document
well that's another Norm blown into a
thousand pieces
at this point we have to assume that the
Democrats will stop at nothing to turn
this 2024 election in their favor
regardless of what's happening in the
economy foreign policy the Border all of
it
now this isn't about preserving
democracy for them it's not about
pursuing equal application of Justice or
the rule of law this is about winning a
bare Knuckles Brawl for the future of
the country
so tonight I want to be very clear no
real conservative with a real chance of
reaching higher office is going to
escape this unbridled assault this is
not all about trump it goes Way Beyond
him
so you agree with Democrats though on
the Perpetual Wars the open border or
rolling over for China implicitly or
explicitly you agree with all that maybe
on the trans agenda as well and
generally you'll be safe you won't be
targeted otherwise the new Norm is
submit or die
but just as they did during covid
I think the Democrats are
underestimating the tolerance of the
American people for this Banana Republic
style approach to governance and to the
legal system
we certainly don't pay taxes to support
policies that we don't like and that
don't work and then are turned against
us
there's a growing multi-ethnic Coalition
forming across this country of people
and parents who are organizing and
unafraid
and they too will use every legal Avenue
they see fit
to protect their children so they're not
used as guinea pigs for cultural
marxists running our schools protect
their economy their savings all of it
because of what's happening right now in
our country
we didn't ask for this battle but we
will not sit back and let them run this
country into the ground without doing
everything in our power to turn things
around Trump or no Trump this country
has to be saved
it's Trump they're after now oh yeah
they're after him and we don't know how
this is all going to play out
but if we don't beat them politically
it will be all of us who's targeted
those of us at least who don't comply
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else